im hessischen Kassel rüstet die Stadt
beim Thema Fahrradparkplätze richtig auf
überall werden neue Bügel zum abstellen
und anschließen installiert kostenpunkt
840.000 Euro aber die Diebstahlsicherung
ist nicht diebstahlsicher mit einer
einfachen Rohrzange kann man die
Halterung der Bügel lösen und die Dinger
ganz leicht ausbauen wenn es eigentlich
eine Diebstahlsicherung sein soll aber
man dann auch als Laie diese
Fahrradständer ganz schnell ja
hochnehmen kann und die Fahrräder
entwenden kann sehe ich da irgendwie
nicht den Sinn drin und wenn Sie hier
mit einer ganz normalen Zange die Dinger
aufmachen dann sind sie weg ich kann es
nicht glauben also ich denke es hätten
Experten doch wissen müssen dass das so
leicht geht bis Ende des Jahres will die
Stadt insgesamt 950 Fahrradbügel
aufstellen
wir machen mit Frank Bierschenk den wir
zufällig auf der Straße treffen einen
Test wie lange brauchen völlige leihen
um sein Fahrrad zu klauen erste Schraube
auf
zweite Schraube auf Bügel rausgehoben
fertig wir haben keine 30 Sekunden
benötigt es scheint schon relativ
schnell zu gehen das war ich doch
erstaunt anders als so eine alte schäse
wo die auch nicht mehr klauen aber
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich ein Ding
gut Bier schenkrad war eher ein altes
Schätzchen aber mit solch einem 6000 €
Rad ist es genauso einfach
wenig Sinn geben das Ganze wenn ich hier
praktisch mit einem Hand umdrehe Fahrrad
mitnehmen kann indem ich einfach die
Schrauben löse und einfach das Fahrrad
ins Auto einstecken kann wo ich gesehen
habe würde ich hier kein Fahrrad mehr
abschließen die Kasseler Stadtverwaltung
verweist darauf dass ich derartige
Halterungen bei normalen
Verkehrsschildern schon bewertet hätten
diese können beispielsweise bei
Veranstaltungen Baumaßnahmen oder
Notfällen besser und für den
Steuerzahler kostengünstiger entfernt
und nach Beendigung wieder montiert
werden
diese einfache Handhabung macht es lang
Fingern aber richtig leicht
absolute Fehlplanung da finde ich jetzt
jedenfalls macht ja keinen Sinn da ich
jetzt weiß dass die da so lose sind
würde ich das dann nicht anschließen
dann kann man es ja an der Laterne oder
irgendwo anders anschließen Radlern
Kassel sollten also ganz genau
hinschauen wo sie ihr Rad abstellen und
anschließen denn die Stadt ist von Ihrem
System weiterhin felsenfest überzeugt
und wird wohl auch nichts daran ändern